welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Leslie Harkema an assistant professor
of Spanish at Yale University her
research focuses on 19th and 20th
century Peninsular literature with a
particular interest in how
post-enlightenment literature in Spain
response to political religious and
scientific discourses within modernity
today we'll talk with professor Harkema
about her current book project which is
a study of the relationship between the
prolific essayist and poet Miguel de
Unamuno and a group of writers known in
the 1920s as the young literature
welcome professor Harkema thank you very
much for having me so tell us about
Miguel de Unamuno who is he uh well you
know Mona was one of the central
intellectual figures in early 20th
century Spain the period leading up to
the Spanish Civil War he actually died
while under house arrest at the very
beginning of the civil war and he was
under house arrest and he was there due
to the Francoist forces who are keeping
him under house arrest he was born in
the 19th century in the basque country
and actually spent most of his adult
life in Salamanca which is closer to the
center of Spain in Madrid and he was a
professor of Greek actually at the
University there and became the rector
of the University of Salamanca so pretty
high profile figure he's most well known
today for his novels which are read
fairly widely throughout the world as
well as for his philosophical work kind
of in the existentialist tradition he
was very influenced by Soren Kierkegaard
for example there's an anecdote that he
taught himself Danish in order to read
Kierkegaard in the original
but he was also a poet a dramatist
obviously a pedagogue a teacher and also
a frequent commentator on all kinds of
social issues in Spain in this period
I'm particularly interested in him as a
public intellectual as an essayist and
also as a poet okay so what is it about
him that led you to study him what
speaks to you um it's interesting I he's
one of the Spanish authors that everyone
reads when they're studying Hispanic
literature but I first got into namu
know when I was translating some of his
early poetry into English while still
working on my doctoral degree and when
you translate literary texts especially
poetry you have to reach a sort of
intimacy with the the author of the
original work and I became fascinated
with the Munoz poetics his relationship
to poetry which is something I hadn't
heard much about but which I've come to
recognize is fundamental for his
thinking about art and and really across
the board and his work this led me to
realize that he actually has a poetic
legacy in Spanish literature in this
period the early 20th century which
hadn't really been studied or it might
be better to say it was forgotten by
scholars and this led me to thinking
about his impact on writers who grew up
reading him in the 1910s and 1920s and
especially this issue that I talk about
in my my book of youth and the rise of
youth culture in the early 20th century
and so let's talk about your book
project tell us about it
sure the title of the book in progress
is Spanish modernism and the aesthetics
of youth and in it I analyzed the way
kind of a broad obsession or a
fascination with youth in early
twentieth century Europe affected
Spanish literature during what's known
in Spanish cultural history as the
Silver Age laila de plata which dates
from the turn of the century to about
again the
Civil War and during this whole period
in Europe youth is really ubiquitous if
we're thinking of the founding of the
Boy Scouts in 1906 or the premiere of JM
Barrie's Peter Pan the play or James
Joyce's novel a portrait of the artist
as a young man Jesus all over the place
also in war propaganda during World War
one or even later in the fascist
movements of the 1920s and 30s I argue
in my book that youth had a special
metaphorical significance for Spain
during this period because for many
years even centuries before this Spain
had been seen as somehow immature or
underdeveloped as a nation the idea was
that it was modernizing more slowly than
other countries such as Germany England
or France primarily of course this
wasn't really the case a lot of recent
scholarship has shown that modernity
came unevenly to all of these countries
and in some ways Spain was really on the
cutting edge of whatever we mean by
modernity but it was certainly perceived
that way by many intellectuals in Europe
and especially within Spain as well two
of them no Munoz contemporaries Joaquin
Costa and the philosopher and Jose
Ortega I guess set both while they talk
a lot about you think they argue that
Spain in some way is too immature and
that it needs to grow up as a nation be
be more mature more adults okay so let's
talk about the young literature and its
relationship to oh no Mona sure sure my
argument in the book is that you know
munot really embraces this idea of Spain
as a mature young relative to other
parts of Europe and but why do you think
that is it's weird the way that he talks
about youth in general it's all over the
place in his work he celebrates it he
uses it as a metaphor for talking about
religious faith one aspect of Spanish
culture that sometimes the scene is
holding Spain back in terms of the
enlightenment and she talks about it in
the context of politics he sees new
political movements especially socialism
in Spain at the time as young movements
and also in in poetics its itself so
he's always for him youth is always the
term he's going to hold up as positive
against an old civilization okay so with
these younger writers who were actually
were younger than he was this group
called La Habana that I thought at a
young literature that forms in the 1920s
what happens is all of these writers
were reading Unamuno especially at the
age when they were adolescents Wow and
they were inspired by what he wrote and
also by the interaction they had with
him in person so they didn't just read
him they also met him at places like the
residencia days through the end days
which was the center in Spain where
Garcia Lorca Federico Garcia Lorca lived
along with Salvador Dali and Luis buñuel
a few years ago there was a movie made
called Little Ashes that talks about
their the time that these artists spent
there in any case the residencia
estudiantes was a meeting point for all
of these younger artists and when I'm
unna also spent a great deal of time
there as well mm-hmm giving lectures
talking with these younger writers he
wrote to many of them extended
correspondence with them and all of them
whether they had a closer relationship
with moon a moon or not and I study some
of those who are closest to him book all
of them recognized him as a kind of
poetic predecessor and a maestro so they
were publishing his poems and their own
journals they were including him in
their anthologies so it's interesting
that these writers who are often not
associated with Unamuno who's a who was
older
than actually look to him quite a bit
and had a great deal of intimacy with
him surrounding this idea of youth as
central to poetic creation and artistic
creation and did that continue as he
grew older and also the young literature
group grew older
that's a great question actually well in
some ways when the young literature was
forming he was already an old man which
may well what do you mean by old man
another question he was in his 60s at
this time okay which certainly wouldn't
be considered all necessarily today but
in the span of that period what search
for nine words and then Howard how old
were the young writers they were in
their 20s and 30s
yeah so and as I said they were started
to read him probably in their teens
already
so when they're aging that's a great
question what happens in Spain is that
the Civil War hits that puts an end to
know Munoz life puts an end to some of
the younger writers lives like Federico
Garcia Lorca it's well known that he was
killed by the Nationalists at the
beginning of the war that was killed
Unum uno died under house arrest okay
Lorca who's maybe the best known poet
outside of Spain today was killed
roughly just a few months before Monroe
died I'm a nationalist so the war puts
an end to youth in Spain in some ways
and those who survive are either they
either remain in Spain some of them
become fascist and and work within the
government actually some are exiled but
in my book I argue that all of them take
this idea of youth from unamuno and use
it in different ways so it's fascinating
to see in the late 20s and early 30s for
example you have young writers who are
both of communist leanings and fascist
leanings who are citing Munoz early work
to justify their visions for a
rejuvenation
Spanish culture very interesting so how
did ona Mona's concept of youth shape
Spain's Silver Age well I would say
again it really reaches very wide in the
period but I think unamuno more than any
of his contemporaries really those of
his same generation if you will
strove to invert the hierarchy between
Earth a hierarchical relationship
between adulthood and youth as I said
before youth for him was always
conceptually preferable preferable to
age in his vindication of youth and
young people inspired many writers to to
run with their own ideas let's say so
his impact in a way anticipates the
importance of youth culture throughout
the twentieth century because what he
was doing was encouraging young people
in a sense to use the term from the
1960s to question authority right and
that's what made his work interesting to
young people in the in Spain in the
early 20th century and I think it's also
what makes them interesting to readers
today into my students who read him in
college classrooms and and basically I
guess readers today is there a certain
universal appeal to his writing I think
so I think in that sense especially his
writing is so playful and again this is
seen in some of his best-known novels
and people often read his novel nabla
mist which really is very playful and in
which he actually makes himself into a
character in the novel and has a debate
with one of the characters over who is
the real author of the story who really
has control of this story this kind of
play with authority in the text I think
is very interesting and it's something
that worked throughout his the various
of genres in which he wrote so his
poetry as well I do think that is the
timeless appeal of
work and the reason why so many young
people are attracted to it right well
very interesting thank you so much for
being here with us today and sharing
some of your work thanks again for
having me for more information about
Professor Harkema please visit our
website at Yale edu slash McMillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the McMillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you